komplett verschleierte frauen sind ein
problem
das zumindest sagen immer mehr menschen
auch in der schweiz
ich selber reden ja allerdings die augen
wenn ich höre welches rhetorische
geschützt in der debatte aufgefahren
wird von einem kulturkampf ist die rede
von einer wertedebatte von einer
entwürdigung der frau das ist unser
ständig haus die wahrscheinlichkeit
klein ist in der schweiz überhaupt eine
frau mit burka anzutreffen
offensichtlich geht es auch ums prinzip
doch um welches zeit für uns die debatte
philosophisch aufzurollen und mal
richtig in die tiefe zu bohren
zu diesem zweck habe ich mir heute zwei
gäste ins studio geholt
es sind dies christine ob sie ist
professorin für philosophie an der
universität im cern und sie hat soeben
dieses buch hiermit herausgegeben
migrationsland schweiz 15 vorschläge für
die zukunft
und bei uns ist auch reinhard merkel es
professor für strafrecht und
rechtsphilosophie an der universität
hamburg
auch er hat sich wiederholt zur kopftuch
debatte und zur flüchtlingskrise zu wort
gemeldet herzlich willkommen
ja frau habe ich hab schon gesagt man
sagt die burka debatte sei auch eine
wertedebatte ein stück stoff was hat das
zu tun mit werten ja zunächst mal nichts
oder wenig würde ich auch sagen und ich
bin auch wie sie erstaunt über die
heftigkeit dieser debatte die sich an
diesem stück stoff festmacht zunächst
mal würde ich sagen kleider haben etwas
zu tun mit nutzen und sie nützlich sind
oder nicht und dann mit geschmack ob sie
einen gefallen oder nicht
aber manchmal gibt es natürlich schon
kleidungsstücke oder einzelne teile
eines kleidungsstücks die etwas
repräsentieren die symbolhaft für etwas
stehen die eine zugehörigkeit ausdrücken
und dann kommen werte mit den spiel und
das ist sicher bei der bordkante fall
gibt es eigentlich aus dem recht
betrachtet irgendwelche historischen
vorläufern man gesagt hat dieses
kleidungsstück verbieten sie hören oder
sehen an meinen zuhörern dass ich nicht
ganz sicher wenn also
ich vermute dass es das gegeben hat bei
in der geschichte bei kleidungsstücken
die symbolisch etwas ausgestrahlt haben
etwas besorgt haben und bei denen dann
die symbolische hinweis missbilligt
wurde aber ganz genau kann ich das jetzt
nicht sagen also wir hatten natürlich
hier in unseren ländern die kurz durch
diskussionen die aber ein bisschen
harmloser sozusagen verläuft und
verlaufen ist als die debatte über die
burka und wir kommen sich auch die
grünen dazu ganz genau weiß ich das
nicht es ist ja auch irgendwie etwas
ungewöhnliches den leuten zu sagen das
darf so anziehen und jenes nicht schauen
wir uns doch die argumente mal genauer
an
eines der argumente dass jetzt dauernd
in der schweiz wiederholt war nicht
unter anderem beispielsweise von
regierungsrat mario fehr in der sf
talkshow schawinski
der hat gesagt es gehört zur liberalen
gesellschaft hinzu dass man sich ins
gesicht sehen kann
stimmt das wort ja das gesicht oder ins
gesicht schauen würde ich schon sagen
ist in unserer gesellschaft positiv
konnotierten uns in die augen begrüßen
uns mit der hand lächeln uns zu das sind
so kurz unserer gesellschaft die etwas
positives zunächst mal signalisieren
aber gleichzeitig gibt es dann natürlich
ganz viele spielorten
es gibt viele menschen die sind nicht
verschleiert und schauen einen trotzdem
nicht in die augen
sie verstecken sich und sie geben auch
nicht die hand zu gehen eine maus den
weg also es gibt an verschiedene formen
des verschleuderns ohne schleier und in
diesem zusammenhang finde ich auch
spannend dass der begriff person ja aus
dem lateinischen persona kommt und maske
heißt also es gibt auch so eine spur die
eben uns aus person aus maskierte
darstellt als leute die gelernt haben
sich in der öffentlichkeit nicht
vollständig zu zeigen
vielleicht müssen wir mit dem
vollständig zeigen auch noch präzisieren
wenn vom burka-verbot die rede ist dann
sind zwei dinge eigentlich damit
tangiert das ist einerseits wirklich die
burka mit dem gitter über den augen dem
stoffgitter aber andererseits auch der
niqab also der schleier der einen
schlitz für die augen offen lässt wenn
man also die augen noch sieht aber
zurück zu diesem thema ohne scheu hat in
der nz im freute
auch betont im verweis auf den
französischen philosophen immanuel linas
das eigentlich aufklärung und am piz
haben den hand gehen
in einem bestimmten aus der hand
liegenden sind kann man das sagen die
frage ist nur welche normativen am ende
vielleicht rechtlichen konsequenzen man
daraus ableiten kann
ich glaube dass die these so zu eng und
zu sozusagen belanglos formuliert wird
es geht nicht wirklich darum ob das
wahrnehmen des antlitzes des anderen
irgend eine konstitutive bedingung des
gemeinsamen menschseins ist sondern es
geht darum welche voraussetzungen wir
machen in einer zivilen gesellschaft die
sozusagen als ganze auch für die
ressourcen hinreichend glaubhaft sein
muss die wir brauchen damit die
rechtsordnung funktionieren kann eine
rechtsordnung die nur übergestülpt würde
über unwillige die eigentlich keine
zivile gesellschaft bilden wollen oder
bei denen es überhaupt kein kohärenz
gefühl innerlich gibt mit den anderen
die den derselben rechtsordnung
unterworfen sind die kann nicht
funktionieren und interessant daran ist
dass der europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte in der entscheidung über
das französische burka-verbot in vieler
hinsicht unzulänglich aber versucht hat
dieses argument zu formulieren die
franzosen selbst haben das auch
formuliert nicht so sehr das gesicht
sehen ist wichtig sondern bestimmte
voraussetzungen einer zivilen
kommunikations gemeinschaft als
bedingung einer funktionierenden rechts
und diese voraussetzungen haben etwas zu
tun mit dem sehen des gesichtes oder
zeigen das gesicht hin offen gestanden
nicht so sehr dass jemand das gesicht
sehen kann sondern mit dem
demonstrativen geste denn jemand der
sich immer verschleiert in der
öffentlichkeit an die anderen aussendet
jemand der das wahrnimmt und irritiert
ist dass andere leute frauen nur mit
burka zu sehen sind sagt nicht ich bin
doch interessiert zu sehen was die für
gesichter überhaupt nicht sondern er
sagt ich rede ist wäre eine geste die
demenz
tief sagt ich gehöre nicht zu deutlich
in der suppe ok ich gehöre nicht zu euch
das da haben sie jetzt noch einen
schlenker gemacht er nicht passt zu dem
was ich fragen wollt ich wollte
eigentlich sagen es gibt auch ganz viele
menschen die dauernd demonstrieren dass
sie nicht lust haben auf kommunikation
sie gucken dauern aufs handy
sie haben ohrstöpsel drehen sie tragen
sonnenbrillen also wieso um gottes
willen muss man eigentlich signalisieren
dass man kommunikationsweg ist fragt ja
das scheint mir auch also die
verweigerung der kommunikation ist ja
zunächst mal erlaubt also es ist selbst
ein teil von kommunikation zu
signalisieren ich will nicht mit dir
reden wir kommen dann natürlich darauf
wo die grenzen dieser verweigerung der
kommunikative täter der kommunikation
des gesprächs verläuft und ob es diese
grenze gibt aber zunächst mal im
öffentlichen raum zu signalisieren ich
will mit dir nichts zu tun haben
das machen viele das spüre ich auch an
personen die überhaupt keinen schleier
tragen oder dann auch wenn man sagt das
gesicht ist so wichtig fällt im moment
auch immer auf viele junge gerade urbane
gestylte männer lassen sich diese langen
bärte wachsen und tragen dann dunkle
sonnenbrillen dazu das ist auch eine
veränderung des gesichts natürlich kann
man sagen man erkennt sie noch aber es
ist trotzdem auch ein spiel mit mit
nicht erkennbar sein oder sich nicht
zeigen oder gerade in vielen
jugendkulturen hat das sich nicht zeigen
durch eine copy und so weiter sich
irgendwie abgrenzen eben auch
kulturtraditionen stimme völlig zu das
gehört zu den liberalen grundrechten zu
sagen ich demonstriere jetzt habe ich
mal vorsichtig gelegentlich dass ich in
der öffentlichkeit nicht als teilnehmer
an irgendeiner art kommunikation
wahrgenommen werden werden wir nähern
uns dem eigentlichen problem dass
besteht der minister das ist einzelne
leute gibt die diese art von totaler
abgrenzung machen wir akzeptieren wenn
einzelne menschen als eremiten leben
wollen vollständig in ordnung ins
kloster eintreten einen schleier das ist
ehrensache
das scheint nur bei musliminnen eine
dimension sozusagen der öffnung sowohl
in der quantität als auch was die
zeitliche dimension der zukunft an
zu haben wenn das hinreichend viele mal
nehmen wir mal als philosophen operieren
wir gerne ja mit gedankenexperimente
nehmen wir mal an das sind nicht wenige
in deutschland etwa 800 frauen oder in
frankreich zweieinhalbtausend die immer
voll verschleiert gehen sondern nehmen
in deutschland haben wir heute 8
millionen muslime sind es irgendwann mal
zweieinhalb millionen
dann wird das tatsächlich ein problem
und wir müssen vorsichtig versuchen zu
ergründen worin genau das problem
besteht
wenn also eine hinreichend große gruppe
aus gründen die einer anderen oder
mehrheit der anderen leute sozusagen
halbwegs aspekt religiöse gründe
aber da ist er aus sicht der ethik ist
doch in diesem moment kann man auch
sagen ein stück weit einen dammbruch
argument auf dem tisch dass man denkt
und gottes willen wo für das dann noch
hin und in der schweiz weiss man gemäss
umfragen 99,9 der muslime die bei uns
leben legen eine solche
vollverschleierung ab
also es kann keine rede davon sein dass
man denkt bald werden alle plötzlich so
eine vorschreibung also ich würde wenn
ich das sagen habe ich will das auch
nicht sagen
diese gefahr droht nicht dass eine große
mehrheit der muslimischen frauen sich
voll verschleiern will ich möchte nur
dieses gedankenexperiment machen um
genau zu ergründen was sind denn die
eigentlichen gründe der irritation und
die werden erst sichtbar wenn man sich
vorstellt eine sehr große zahl von
frauen würde das tun jetzt kriegt man in
den blick was die leute innerlich
irritiert und man kann das nur wirklich
in den blick kriegen wenn man es im
gesamtkontext von integrationsproblemen
sieht es geht nicht nur um die burka
wenn nur dass das thema wäre wäre es
keines es geht darum dass man das gefühl
hat hier entsteht eine kultur
konfrontation mit einer uns fremden und
in manchen hinsichten unheil
mir scheint mit solchen gedanken
experimenten gerade auch jetzt in
unserem heutigen kontext entstehen auch
noch ängste also von daher würde ich
eher davon absehen jetzt sozusagen
gerade in unserem konkreten politischen
kontext solche die gedankenexperimente
zu schnell in die diskussion mit
einzuführen sondern eher daran zu
erinnern es ist eben nicht so
es ist eine verschwindende minderheit
in der schweiz lebende muslime und
muslime gegen muss man in diesem fall
sagen die eine burka tragen die sich in
dieser ort verschleiern und von daher
möchte ich eher innerhalb dieser debatte
daran erinnern dass es eben nicht so ist
es ist eine minderheit es man kann
darüber diskutieren was es heißen würde
aber ich würde nicht zu schnell dazu
kommen weil ich eher daran erinnern
möchte gerade weil es so auch
aufwallungen gibt weil so viele ängste
und verunsicherung da sind eher daran
erinnern
es ist nicht so es ist eine kleine
gruppe von frauen in der schweiz riesig
so verschleiern ja gehen wir noch einmal
kurz zurück bevor ich zum nächsten
argument kommen möchte zu diesem thema
dass man sozusagen ich sage es mal ganz
martialisch sich mit offenem die hier
begegnen sollte dass das zu unserer
kultur irgendwie dazugehört dass dieses
argument dass wir sozusagen wird richtet
sich unser gesicht zu zeigen dass lassen
sie also nicht gelten so pauschal habe
ich sie richtig verstanden richtig also
ich spiele ja hier ein bisschen in
mancher hinsicht den advocatus diaboli
aber ich finde und das möchte ich gerne
ergänzen zu dem was sie gesagt habe es
schon richtig den leuten zu sagen eure
ängste sind übertrieben
er projiziert das in einer in eine
zukunft und riesige zahl von frauen so
rumlaufen wird das wird nicht der fall
sein das ist richtig andererseits dürfen
wir die irritationen großer teile der
bevölkerung nicht arrogant ignorieren
wir müssen sie in einem anderen sinn als
die wohlfeilen politiker sprüche das
immer tun ernst nehmen nämlich
analysieren und uns fragen was ist denn
wirklich möglicherweise dran und ich
kann nur sagen an manchen dingen ist
etwas dran wir müssen versuchen bis in
den blick zu kriegen aber zu sagen jeder
hat die pflicht sein gesicht zu zeigen
ist nur dann gehen jedoch ein stück
weiter zum zweiten argumenten rabatten
das ist das argument eine burka sei
frauenverachtend oder sogar gegen die
würde der frau vergleich darf ich noch
etwas was ich gerade vergessen habe
hinzufügen
es gibt natürlich kontext in unserer
gesellschaft in denen das zeigen des
gesichts unabdingbar ist
wir hatten eine entscheidung vor
ungefähr sieben jahren des kanadischen
supreme court da ist eine
vollverschleierte muslimin geladen
als zeugen in einem strafverfahren das
geht nicht das gericht hat zwar
sozusagen das kontrovers diskutiert dann
aber mehrheitlich entschieden sie muss
sich entscheiden
aber sonst die rechte der verteidigung
beschränkt werden es gibt andere kontext
ich möchte nicht dass in grundschulen
vollverschleierte lehrerinnen lehrern
das halte ich für indiskutabel aus
verschiedenen und über die schule kann
ich später noch sprechen die
zeugenaussage dass die nichts mit burka
gemacht werden kann genau dieses urteil
gibt es das kann man ja auch
nachvollziehen man würde dann auch sagen
man muss eine sonnenbrille
beispielsweise abnehmen durch weil es
dazugehört dass der richter dem der depp
der zeugin dem zeuge in die augen
blicken kann
das ist in der schweiz ja auch so also
auch auf einen kreisbüro auf der
gemeinde wo es auch um identitätskarten
und so weiter geht dann muss man sich
entscheiden da gibt es auch die
rechtsgrundlage bereits jetzt gut also
danke für diesen hinweis gehen wir zum
zweiten argument zu dieser frage ob die
burka frauenverachtend ist auch da gibt
es ja viele personen die das immer
wieder als argument einbringen
ich frage sie jetzt ist die burka
frauenverachtend ja so formuliert ist
schwierig zu beantworten tatsächlich ich
finde wenn man sagt sie ist ein symbol
die für etwas steht dann würde ich sagen
ist es für mich ein problematische etwas
problematisches was dahinter steht für
mich persönlich was nicht heißt dass man
gleichzeitig auch für ein verbot gegen
eine burka sein muss ich würde sowieso
und das noch eine klammer die ich zum
vorgänger punkt machen möchte wenn man
von verboten dieser ort spricht und das
gesicht aufwertet was schon ein
wichtiger punkt ist dann würde ich eben
von verhüllungsverbot sprechen und nicht
von einem burka-verbot als da müsste man
generell sagen männer und frauen haben
in jeder ort die verhüllung nicht das
ist nicht erlaubt da müsste man auch die
karneval noch mal anschauen und so
weiter verschiedene facetten der wurde
der karneval spielt doch einfach mit
symbolen und verkleidungen maskierung
der karneval ist natürlich genau eine
bestärkung dessen dass das freie zeigen
des gesichts wichtig ist in unserer
kultur weil es eine klare ausnahme
situation war lang
die gesellschaftliche situation wo man
eine andere rolle spiele wo man sich
eben vorstellen durfte man nicht sagen
musste wer man ist also insofern war es
und das wusste man ganz genau wann
beginnt es und wann hört es auf das
waren ausnahmesituation in denen man
eben genau nicht erkennbar sein muss das
bestätigt eigentlich eher dass das
gesicht zeigen schon ein ein wichtiger
punkt ist aber wenn es das ist dann muss
man alle arten von verfügung anschauen
und nicht ein burka verbot von der
begrifflichkeit da muss man ein
verhüllungsverbot diskutiert in meinen
augen
ja es ist wahr und verachten ich glaube
wofür es steht es steht schon für jetzt
komme ich mit dem begriff werte die für
mich fragwürdig sind aber jetzt nicht
nur in bezug auf eine frau sondern
generell ist ein verständnis schwingt
damit dass eben eine person als sich als
individuum nicht in der öffentlichkeit
erkennbar machen will als es ist eine
ente wenn ich ein solches stück stoff
anziehe bin ich in einer weise
vergleichbar mit anderen menschen und
man erkennt meine individualität
offensichtlich wenig an und es ist ein
end individualisierungs moment und da
mir persönlich diese persönliche
freiheit und individualität so wichtig
ist finde ich persönlich es ist es ist
schwierig das man in der öffentlichkeit
diese entindividualisierung dann
realisiert und eigentlich zeigt man ist
im privaten eine person eine entwicklung
aber im öffentlichen bereich eben nicht
und das sind schon aspekte die ich
persönlich probleme an dieser ort ich
würde für mich selber keine burka tragen
wollen aus eben nicht heißt das habe ich
schon gesagt dass man das generell
verbieten sollte noch eine andere
dimension
ich finde schon dass das richtig ist was
sie sagen aber ich glaube der eigentlich
wichtige punkt ist ein anderer nämlich
der verdacht dass dahinter nicht
irgendwie sozusagen eine individualität
steht die frau die sich seltsam
entscheidet sondern eine externe andere
macht und zwar eine maskuline macht im
islam
und ich kann nur sagen wenn sie mich
direkt fragen habe ich die burka für
frauenfeindlich
frauenverachtend da halte ich glaube das
sind sehr vielen fällen eine dominanz
aus der religion aus einer männlich
dominierten religion stammt die sehr
wohl frauenverachtend ist das heißt aber
nicht dass man der erwachsenen frau die
die burka tragen will sagen kann wir
wissen das besser als du du wirst
eigentlich missbraucht du wirst
misshandeln du wirst verächtlich
behandelt und deswegen verbieten wir dir
dass das geht nicht diese art von
paternalismus widerspricht bestimmten
normativen grundprinzipien unserer
liberalen gesellschaftsordnung
das ist der eine punkt das kann man den
frauen mit diesem argument nicht
verbieten darf man ihnen damit nicht
verbieten
andererseits ist an dem argument
selbstverständlich etwas dran
dahinter ist eine dominanten männliche
religion die die frauen als sobald
herren behandelt in den allermeisten
fällen diese frauen sind so sozialisiert
worden ist man kann nicht sein muss gar
nicht so sein dass der ehemann zu hause
sagt zu holen jetzt befehle ich dir das
nur so gehst du in die öffentlichkeit so
an ihm mag das mit einer sozialisierung
die das eben vermittelt innerlich
angenommen haben das sind euch
eigentlich bei der frage ob die frau die
burckhardt selbstbestimmt tragen kann
kann sich für sich selber wählen ich
möchte dieses kleidungsstück anziehen
und in diesem kontext liegt es natürlich
nahe auf alice schwarzer zu kommen die
feministin aus deutschland die ja immer
wieder betont es ist absolut undenkbar
dass eine frau wirklich selbst bestimmt
ihren infotischen sinn diese burg
anziehen würde und sie war zu gast in
der nachrichtensendung 10 vor 10 des
schweizer fernsehens am letzten mittwoch
schauen wir uns ein ausschnitt
wir glauben allen ernstes dass es frauen
gibt die wirklich freiwillig unter
diesem leichentuch verschwinden
und da dass frauen in anderen ländern zu
millionen geprügelt und gezwungen werden
ich muss ihnen sagen für die
selbstbestimmung von frauen kämpfen
heißt nicht dass man alles was einzelne
frauen tun auch gut
ist sie wissen ja vielleicht dass frauen
auch dinge machen die problematische
traurig bin da anderer meinung ich denke
dass es frauen gibt sie tatsächlich auch
dazu stehen auch mit jahr dazu stehen
und sagen ich trage diese burka
freiwillig ich will das machen sind vor
allem auch zum teil jüngere frauen
oftmals auch konvertiten muss man sagen
ein eigenes interessantes phänomen die
diese burka wählen würde sagen ist es
dann fast schon eine freiheitliche akt
weil sie sich sie brechen mit ihrer
tradition und entscheiden sich dafür
von daher würde ich nochmal sagen die
aussage die burka als frauenverachtend
finde ich schwierig generell zu
beantworten sondern es ist in jedem fall
zu fragen warum aus welchen gründen
trägt eine frau die burg und ich bin
auch nicht sicher ob es nicht doch viele
frauen gibt ebenso wie männer die im
grunde einfach auch angst haben vor
freiheit also mir kommt da immer die
rede des großinquisitor ich weiß nicht
ob sich die brüder karamasow und diese
vorstellung die mir sehr nahe ist und
nicht also ein liberaler und überzeugung
ist dass der mensch freiheit haben
möchte möchte frei seine individualität
dem fall können möchte mitbestimmen
können selbst bestimmen können das ist
natürlich fraglich ob das wirklich alle
menschen wollen oder ob es menschen gibt
die froh sind wenn sie diese diese bürde
diese anspruchsvolle diese
anspruchsvolle aufgabe eben abgeben
können ich glaube es ist verblendet
davon auszugehen dass es nur frauen
unter der burka sind die so denken
sondern genauso eben auch auf der
anderen seite menschen die so schnell
dann auch ein burka-verbot wollen denke
ich genauso sind diese menschen
überfordert von einer ort freiheitlichen
lebensort und warum sind sie gefordert
das wäre dann die frage andererseits
muss man ja auch sagen stellt sich doch
die frage warum diskutieren eigentlich
dauernd über diese burka über den
burkini neuerdings auch also diesen
ganzkörperanzug schwimmen gehen zu
können es geht immer irgendwie um den
frauenkörper und sie haben ja vorhin
gesagt herr merkel naja das ist halt
irgendwie ausdruck einer maskulinen
kultur darum ist mir gleich noch
sprechen über den kulturbegriff aber
ausdruck
maskulin kultur liegen die die frau
irgendwie sobald herrn betrachtet aber
gleichzeitig wenn man bei die literatur
von musliminnen liest beispielsweise
frauen aus saudi arabien die unter dem
wahabismus leben einer extremen form des
islams dann sagen die jungs sind ganz
andere probleme viel viel größer wie
diese vollverschleierung die
beispielsweise die vormundschaft dass
sie kein recht darauf haben selber
entscheiden zu dürfen wohin sie gehen
wollen wohin sie reisen wollen dass sie
nicht auto fahren dürfen und so weiter
also anders gesagt ist nicht diese ganze
debatte auch ausdruck davon dass wir
einfach nur auf ein bestimmtes ding
gucken nämlich kleidungsstücke der frau
und da haben mich aber gar nicht
wirklich für die rechte der frau
interessieren
ja das glaube ich offen gestanden nicht
jedenfalls jemand der ich oder jemand
wie ich diskutiert mit interessen auch
an den rechten der frau und natürlich
vor selbstverständlichen hintergründen
die wir überhaupt nicht mehr in frage
stellen das geht nicht zu sagen frauen
sind bestimmten hinsichten den männern
sozusagen unterzuordnen das geht einfach
nicht
damit kommt auf was anderes jetzt an der
selbstbestimmung begriff ist ein
relativer begriff
niemand ist absolut frei und
selbstbestimmt immer relativ zu
kulturellen hintergründen zur
sozialisation die man selber genossen
hat oder erleben musste das kann man ja
auch negativ formulieren also in diesem
sinne hat alice schwarzer die ich
manchen kontext sehr schätze hier ganz
sicher unrecht selbstverständlich können
frauen in dem sie in den wir mit dem
begriff autonom verbinden autonom
entscheiden ich ziehe die burg an aber
in sehr vielen fällen auch solche
relativ autonome entscheidungen ist
sozusagen der dominante einfluss ein
kultur hintergrund der ein problem ist
das zu leugnen wäre glaube ich und ist
er wirklich sagen wir mal kategorisch zu
unterscheiden von dem einfluss
beispielsweise der westlichen
schönheitsideale auf frauen frauen die
sagen natürlich freiwilligen bikini an
natürlich mache ich freiwillig eine
brustvergrößerung operation
feministinnen die dagegen sagen
natürlich musst du das nicht freiwillig
ist das nicht ganz an dritte weiter
wenn wir das individuum an gruppen die
individuelle frauen nach ihrer
selbstbestimmung fragen dann sind die
parallelen offensichtlich da gibt es
bestimmte parallelen auch die frauen die
schönheitsoperationen hier machen lassen
entscheiden darüber in dem allein
verbindlichen öffentlichen sind denn
auch die rechtsordnung meint autonom
da hat sich niemand einzumischen
gleichwohl kann man sagen im hintergrund
ist ein ganz anderer fragwürdiges
frauenideal das problem besteht also
diese parallele ist offensichtlich das
problem für viele leute hier besteht nur
dass wir in unserer restlichen
lebensformen bestimmte phänomene
entwickelt haben
die ihre legitimität aus der langsamen
entwicklung so zusammen beziehen die
übertriebene schönheit sucht was äußere
dinge angeht und andere ist das findet
niemand bedrohlich und nun wird man
plötzlich unvermittelt konfrontiert wird
etwas ganz anderes
also in der wahrnehmung ganz anderen aus
einer als ganz fremd empfundenen kultur
und religion die spielt hier natürlich
eine dominante rolle
und dann hat man eine einfachere antenne
offenbar für die kulturellen
hintergründen jemand verdächtig findet
ich finde ich schon richtig beide
diskussionen zu führen und zu sagen was
ist denn mit dem frauenbild der
westlichen gesellschaft entscheiden die
in irgendeinem sinne sozusagen
hinreichend autonom meine antwort ist
beide gruppen von frauen entscheiden
autonom das heißt aber nicht dass wir
die suspekten kultur hinter hörende
ignorieren sollen jedoch mal noch tief
weit ist ganz ganz oft der begriff der
kultur gefallen ist es wirklich richtig
frau abt aus dieser burka debatte eine
sagen die kultur ein kultur streit zu
machen
ob es richtig ist oder nicht kann ich
nicht beurteilen weil es schon so ist
also ich denke wir sind schon in durch
den diskurs jetzt in einer kulturdebatte
drin
ich würde deshalb auch schon sagen die
burka ist ein stück weit auch schon teil
unserer kultur
auch wenn es ein ein kleidungsstück ist
das immer noch mit fremdheit und mit
vielen irritationen besetzt ist oder
nicht
immer bleiben wird wie auch immer aber
es ist schon so aufgeladen es wird von
so vielen künstlern auch bespielt
auch von muslimischen künstlerinnen und
auch von nichtmuslimischen künstler und
künstlerinnen
es ist teil einer kultur debatte in der
eben vor allem würde ich sagen
grundrechte persönliche freiheit und das
verhältnis der geschlechter im zentrum
stehen auch wenn die von einer kultur
debatte sprechen dann tun wir ja so ein
bisschen so als wäre die burka wirklich
ausdruck einer kultur und ich wiederhole
noch einmal ich kann hier auch
vielleicht einen artikel noch bei ziehen
der in der nzz vom freitag erschienen
ist ein kommentar von christoph sigrist
fahrer am grossmünster in zürich der
noch einmal eben darauf hinweist 400.000
muslime in der schweiz 99 dieser
musliminnen und muslimen lehnen diese
burka also man kann nicht davon sprechen
dass das ausdruck ihrer kultur sei also
klar man muss die notwendigen
unterscheidungen machen aber
selbstverständlich ist sozusagen der
druck der in der sozialisierung
sozusagen entstanden sein mag und
gelegentlich auch von den zuständigen
ehemännern ausgeübt wird
religiös informiert hat eine religiöse
wurzeln und das ist eine kultur wurzel
dass das nur ein kleiner teil der
muslime ist ist vollkommen unbestreitbar
gleichwohl ist der hintergrund die
religion und nicht einfach ein sozial
eine neigung eine besondere mode zu
machen und dann kann man sich schon
fragen es gibt eben nicht den islam aber
es gibt strömungen im islam die in einem
höheren grades aspekten als andere und
ich glaube schon dass wir um ihr auf
ihre frage zu kommen dass wir diese
kultur diskussion führen müssen sie ist
nur schwierig und es vermintes gelände
ja wenn man bestimmte begriffe zu
unvorsichtig verwendet dann bestärkt man
gewisse schmutzige stimme die in dieser
debatte laut werden dass wenn man nicht
aber wir müssen und wir tun das wir
versuchen das ja hier
ein anfang so zusagen zu machen wir
müssen versuchen das philosophische
einzuholen was ist eigentlich an dieser
kultur diskussion genau und diese
diskussion tut ja irgendwie auch wer
davor drückt man sich unter umständen
vielleicht auch weil man sich überlegt
haben wir eigentlich eine eigene kultur
also wenn man sagt wir streiten uns über
eine kultur und sagen das gehört nicht
zu unserer kultur müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass wir selber eine kultur
haben haben wir die fragt ja also von
daher würde ich ihn auch bei ihrer
rückfrage vor allem sehr recht geben ich
würde von kulturen sprechen sie haben
die kulturdebatte genannt aber in einer
debatte geht es daneben um
unterschiedliche kultur vorstellungen
und ich denke auch nicht dass an dieser
ball kann nur verhandelt wird das
verhältnis zwischen muslimen und
nichtmuslimen in einer gesellschaft oder
in unserer gesellschaft sondern auch die
frage im umgang mit freiheit und
individualität und selbst wirklich um
innerhalb der der gesamten gesellschaft
die und dort gehen die bruchlinien
nochmal durch ganz andere gruppierungen
auch hindurch also da könnte man auch
andere vielleicht eben konservative
auslegung in anderen religionsgruppen
finden die sich er dann treffen auch in
bezug auf das freiheitsverständnis oder
auf das frauenbild als jetzt nur diese
differenz zwischen muslimen und nicht
muslimen und nicht für die wieder dass
das richtig ist was sie sagen aber mir
fehlt irgendwie was dabei natürlich
haben wir eine vielfalt von kulturen in
unserer gesellschaft wir werden sicher
noch auf die frage gekommen ob wir einen
bestimmten normativen gründen bestand
haben liberale prinzipien
verfassungsprinzipien etwa gleichheit
von mann und frau
die geteilt werden die von allen diesen
kulturen geteilt werden aber auch ein
spezifischer anteil unserer kultur sind
aber sie haben natürlich recht wir haben
ganz unterschiedliche kulturelle
neigungen und philosophen mögen ja
kultur verbindungen vielmehr mit den
philosophen in australien in amerika
haben als mit ihrem nachbarn hier in
zürich oder in berlin
wenn sich ein bayer wenn ich das als
deutscher mal sagen darf und ein
ostfriese in timbuktu treffen
dann mögen sie intensiv und intuitiv
ihre gemeinsame kulturelle die den
gemeinsamen kulturellen hintergrund
empfinden wenn sie sich in oberammergau
treffen empfinden sie eine totale
trennung ihrer beiden
kulturellen unmittelbaren kulturell
neigung das schließt sich aber nicht aus
wir haben große sozusagen großflächige
kollektive intuitionen die sagen das
gehört aus gründen die man dann benennen
muss nicht mehr zu dieser kulturellen
vielfalt in der wir uns trotzdem
normativ miteinander verbunden fühlen
und das ist die behauptung die
aufgestellt wird und unsere aufgabe
finde ich ist zu klären was ist da dran
dann was ist nicht mehr dran
ja dann gehen sie mal los m erkeln also
der hintergrund ist eigentlich die frage
der integration wir diskutieren ja nicht
abstrakt den wert von kulturen sondern
wir stellen die frage ob die 1,5
millionen muslime die wir seit anfang
2015 in deutschland jetzt zusätzlich
bekommen haben integrierbar sind
erste frage natürlich war müssen die
sich integrieren müssen die sich
integrieren und ist das ein
erstrebenswertes ziel oder nicht aber
wenn man das jetzt mal vorläufig als
mindestens erstrebenswertes ziel
formuliert und dafür gibt es gründe
dann stellt sich die frage was mag dem
im weg stehen integration ist eine
aufgabe für die gesellschaft in die
diese migranten kommen aber auch eine
aufgabe für die migranten und nun mag es
kulturelle hemmungen und hintergründe
geben die die integration blockieren
und ich glaube da gibt es jedenfalls
risiken für eine bruchlose integration
und dazu gehören bestimmte religiöse
grundüberzeugungen nicht schlechterdings
des islam hat aber sehr viele muslime
eine religion ist das was die mehrheit
ihrer anhänger aus ihr machen und das
müssen wir schon sehen wir haben
mindestens 45 hinsichten veranlassung
genau hinzugucken das bild ob das
funktionieren kann das betrifft liberale
grundprinzipien das betrifft das
verhältnis von mann und frau
das betrifft die rolle der gewalt in
politischen auseinandersetzungen das
betrifft die rolle oder die die das
gewicht das man freier sexualität
zustimmt und dann aber machen sie jetzt
nicht das fass auf wird das was man
gemeinhin einen kultur alice nehmen
nämlich eine zuschreibung so eine art
kultureller essentiell ismus dass man
sagt ihr menschen die ihr diesen und
diesen religiösen hintergrund haben oder
die aus diesen in diesen ländern kommt
ihr habt auch diese kultur und
eigentlich ist der kultur alles muss
dann nur so etwas wie an rassismus in
einem von ihnen klar wenn das einfach so
daher behauptet wird ist das
indiskutabel
aber es gibt gravierende indizien dafür
dass eine hohe zahl von muslimen zu
einem fundamentalismus tendiert der
kollidiert und darum geht es nicht um
abstrakte kultur inhalte ob die hier
leibnitz kant beethoven und goethe
irgendwie innerlich gut finden lernen
oder nicht ist vollkommen egal da gibt
es keinerlei anspruch das von ihnen zu
verlangen ob sie bestimmte normen
akzeptieren die wir verteidigen müssen
das ist die frage und das ist auch eine
kulturelle frage
man darf das haben sie völlig recht
nicht einfach daher behaupten
wir haben indizien für ein weit höherer
anteil ich möchte ihnen an dieser stelle
herfried münkler einbringen und marina
münkler ganz neu erschienen ihr buch die
neuen deutschen ein land vor seiner
zukunft und einige thesen hier drin ist
achtung wir müssen aufhören die
migrationsdebatte zu islamisieren
also genau dieser punkt lasst uns die
phänomene trennen und erstmal sind das
menschen sozial politische spannungen
die entstehen können es geht um fragen
wie integration im sinne von die schauen
wir dass keine ghettos gebildet werden
wie können wir sicherstellen dass
menschen entfaltungsmöglichkeiten finden
partizipieren können an der gesellschaft
und wenn das gelingt dann werden die
probleme kleiner werden aber die
probleme die entstehen haben nichts zu
tun mit der kultur oder mit den islam
sondern haben etwas damit zu tun die
menschen partizipieren können an der
gesellschaft ja ich bin ihre
ausgangslage war ja gibt es so etwas wie
unsere kultur und sie haben zwei drei
oder vier punkte eigentlich genannt die
sie grundsätzlich offenbar auch nehmen
und da würde ich ihnen zustimmen an
denen kann man entfalten vielleicht was
für viele irgendwie
mit kultur zusammen hängt aber eben auch
wenn es ihnen zu ungenau ist zu sagen
dass es eben immer in bewegung ist der
kulturbegriff oder es gibt sie diese
gegenbewegung dass man sagt ja aber
jetzt gib mal sag mal was es dann
wirklich ist aber gleichzeitig finde ich
eben und stimmig münchner eben zu oder
den beiden münchner zu gleichzeitig ist
die frage was ist überhaupt kultur und
so zu tun als ob es ein eine feste
identität unserer kultur gäbe ist falsch
also es ist ja gerade in der schweiz
kann man sagen ein ein ständiges
zusammenspiel von einflüssen von
austausch von interaktions praktiken im
land in und außerhalb von
unterschiedlichen sozialen gruppierungen
die man auch zuteilen kann regionen oder
bildungsstandards und so weiter
sprachgruppen und dann leben die aber
zusammen und dann ist es plötzlich ganz
viel zu sagen ja wo sind jetzt genau die
differenzen die frage ist dann eher wohl
passieren dinge wo wir sagen das geht
nicht mehr oder das ist doch dann eher
die frage wo und da würde ich auch eben
dabei drei frage der grenzen der
toleranz grenzen der toleranz oder wo
sagt man da müsst ihr jetzt mitmachen
oder sonst haben wir ein problem und
zwar haben wir alle zusammen ein problem
also wo ist diese grenzen denn zu sagen
es gibt normandy müssten alle befolgen
da würde ich noch mal zurück auf das
burka-verbot eben möglich sagen halten
wir den rechtsraum möglichst tief ja
wirklich auf dem boden wo möglichst
viele unterschiedliche lokale
gruppierungen können daran halten wir
uns und dieser raum da bin nicht der
meinung dass ist in deutschland eine
debatte darüber nicht an meinem der muss
absolut durchgesetzt werden gleichzeitig
aber müssen partizipationsmöglichkeiten
geschaffen werden damit diese leute auch
teil dieser politischen gemeinschaft
werden das muss parallel passieren aber
ich weiß nicht ob sie dem zustimmen
doch ich stimme dem zu aber ich habe den
ort begriff wohl ein bisschen
missverständlich verwendet ich meine
nicht nur rechtsnormen jeder deutsche
feuilleton leser kennt den satz unseres
ehemaligen verfassungsrichters ernst
wolfgang böckenförde
der liberale rechtsstaat lebt von
voraussetzungen die er selbst nicht
garantieren kann
die unterhalb der rechtlichen schwelle
eine bedeutung gewinnen und es ist so
dass der rechtsstaat davon lebt von
einer grundsätzlichen loyalität auch zu
dieser normativen struktur die 100 der
rechtsordnung
lassen sie es mich illustriert mit einem
beispiel bin und ich habe das zu hören
gekriegt von jüdischen freundin von mir
in berlin
die sagen ich bin endlich als jüdische
kippa ich gehe nicht mehr nach kreuzberg
wenn mir drei muslimische jugendliche
entgegenkommen kann ich mit 90 95
prozentiger sicherheit drauf rechnen
die spucken mir vor die füße das ist
unterhalb der rechtlichen ordnung das
ist dann heißt nicht verfolgbar
das ist rechtlich nicht fasst machen als
sie dürfen wenn ich irgendwie die
verunreinigung des bürgersteigs in einer
verordnung verboten ist dürfen sie da in
schmucken er sie demonstrieren eine
geste der verachtung und zwar
nachdrücklich und zwar spezifisch
gegenüber juden oder gegenüber
homosexuellen und in anderen moderatoren
formen vielleicht auch gegenüber frauen
das meine ich die rechtsnorm ich meine
eine unterhalb der rechtsordnung
eingezogene normative struktur in der
mann oder wenn man sich in ihr bewegt in
der man dann zeigen kann
ich akzeptiere das nicht lassen sie mich
an dieser stelle das ganz kurz
zusammenfassen ich glaube es ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt oft scheinen wir
uns wenn wir sagen das gehört nicht zu
unserer kultur eigentlich nur zu
beziehen auf so etwas wie verfassung und
rechtsstaatlichkeit wir denken die
menschen die hierher kommen sollen
unsere verfassung und
rechtsstaatlichkeit akzeptieren
damit bringen wir aber zum ausdruck dass
sozusagen ein sagen wir mal in eine
politische rechtliche ordnung akzeptiert
werden sollte und noch nicht eine kultur
und sie sagen jetzt moment war frau
fleisch es gibt aber noch etwas darüber
es gibt noch mehr gucken wo die gewisse
zum beispiel also es gibt genau gibt es
also aber wir können ja nicht aufgrund
von winzigen beispiel in eine riesige
burgen batterien also
die beispiele den groß wo genau reizt
die kultur an der anderen kultur es gibt
eine auch wieder exemplarisch gesagt es
gibt eine viel diskutierte auch
kritisierte aber in der substanz
haltbare studie des
wissenschaftszentrums berlin von 2009
unter 9.000 muslimen in unseren
europäischen ländern und einer ähnlich
großen vergleichsgruppe von christen und
da kriegen sie ergebnisse bei der frage
ist das wort gottes über der
rechtsordnung angesiedelt also ein
stärkeres gebot als die geburt der
rechtsordnung da haben sie bei muslimen
ungefähr 78 prozent die ja sagen
bei christen haben sich sieben bis acht
prozent dann die frage also die fragen
sind so konzipiert gewesen dass sich
daraus ein plausibler begriff von
fundamentalismus ergeben könnte die
frage juden kann man nicht trauen
55 prozent der muslime in unseren
ländern sagen so ist das und 3 prozent
der christen sagen dass und hier haben
sie belege dafür für das was ich auch
vorher schon gemeint habe es gibt einen
weitaus höheren anteil an
fundamentalistisch sozusagen geneigten
muslimen als unter den christen und
jetzt gibt es ein besonders
irritierendes phänomen
die junge generation die nachwächst
tendiert bei den christen dazu ein
liberaler und offener zu werden
bei den muslimen eher im gegenteil die
türkischen eltern die hier vor 40 jahren
zugewandert sind vollkommen sozusagen
liberale deutsche wie jeder der hier
eine lange wurzel sozusagen seiner
verwandtschaft hat aber die kinder
radikalisieren sich viel leichter
die haben sich da zeigt sich auch daran
dass es eben erstens nicht mehr
migration frage ist sondern auch noch
eine ganz grundsätzliche frage woher
diese volle mentalist muss kommt und wie
man gegen fundamentalistische strömungen
jetzt besonders sichtbar in den
muslimischen gemeinschaften aber
überhaupt wie man gegen muss
fundamentalistische strömungen vorgehen
kann was können gesellschaft machen
überall auf der welt wenn es eine
mehrheit gibt oder menschen gibt die
sagen das wollen wir nicht
und ich finde das beispiel mit dem
spucken schon
gut weil das natürlich tatsächlich
wirklich an dieser grenze kratz es ist
rechtlich nicht zu verfolgen
aber es ist eine geste der verachtung
die die irgendwie anstößige ist immer
nicht möchte davor kann man sich auch
fürchten das kann man ablesen wie man
sich davor fürchten man will oder ich
persönlich möchte das nicht dass das das
überhand screen und verachtung es geht
darum zu sagen wir sind was anderes als
ihr mit euch wollen wir nicht dass nicht
soziales problem ich möchte noch mal
zurück zu dem tod der frau ab gerade
gemacht hat er sie haben gesagt das
zeigt sich doch wie jetzt gerade also
diese diese auseinandersetzung zwischen
ihnen es ist nicht eine frage der
migration und es ist damit auch nicht
eine frage der kultur sondern eine frage
der integration also gelingt ist dass
diese menschen hier irgendwie teilhaben
können und dann könnte man doch um
wieder aufs burka-verbot zurückzukommen
sagen dienen nicht solche diskussionen
eigentlich dazu wiederum die differenz
zu betonen statt dass man versucht die
gemeinsamkeiten zu betonen und
vielleicht stärker betont er gehört hier
dazu und wir rechnen mit euch also das
finde ich ganz wichtig dass wir auch
eben selten oder viel zu wenig in meinen
augen wirkt die liberalen kräfte
innerhalb der muslimischen
gemeinschaften anhören einbeziehen
kräftigen denn die sind ja tatsächlich
ganz wichtige brückenbauer
das sind diejenigen die in einer
gesellschaft die der pluralen
freiheitlichen gesellschaft leben und
aber gläubig sind und die eigentlich als
beispiel dienen können wie das
zusammengeht die sind auch in kontakt
zum teil noch mit diesen familien wo
vielleicht auch eltern besorgt sind weil
ihr sohn sich fundamental sierte
radikalisiert das gibt es ja es gibt
eltern die sind besser ob die stellen
vielleicht wir kriegen wir kommen nicht
mehr an den sohn heran
und ich glaube dass man da als
gesellschaft aus ein vorschlag wie man
eben gegen solche fundamentalistische
strömungen wie mit kleinen schritten
vorgehen kann
ich glaube man muss ganz klar die
liberalen kräfte willi braun aufgeklärt
muslimischen kräfte stützen sie in den
medien zu wort kommen lassen und anhören
was sie sagen zum beispiel hier in
diesem 10 14 ein spieler war ja nicht
nur alice schwarzer sondern es war ja
auch eine muslimin der schweiz die sich
immer wieder auch zu wort melden und sie
hat klar gegen das brücker verbot
stellung genommen hat aber auch gesagt
ihr also hat darzustellen genommen und
ich finde solche stimmen ganz wichtig
das sind menschen irgendwie eben und kid
bilden und zeigen es ist möglich
religion auszuleben aber unsere
freiheitlichen werte oder unsere und
ihre freiheitlichen werte gleichzeitig
zu leben
also ich stimme zu aber einfach zu sagen
das ist möglich ignoriert ein besonderes
problem wenn der hintergrund für die
fundamentalistische neigung die religion
ist dann hat der der sich so orientiert
fundamentalist ist subjektiv eine sehr
starke eine überhaupt nicht übertragbare
rechtfertigung nämlich das vermeintliche
wort gottes und das ist das problem
man kann schon sagen haben sie völlig
recht wir müssen viele muslimische
liberale kräfte hier stärken ich habe
studentinnen und studenten die
muslimische sind die sie in ihren
inneren haltungen überhaupt nicht zu
unterscheiden von den anderen studenten
die ich habe völlig richtig aber dass
das schwierige ist und nicht nur eine
aufgabe die uns trifft und betrifft
sondern eine aufgabe die die migranten
die zu uns kommen ihrerseits ernst
nehmen müssten
das muss man schon sehen und wie schwer
sie ist und dass sie in sehr vielen
fällen scheitert erleben wir dauern
selbstverständlich müssen wir versuchen
solche parallelgesellschaften banlieues
wie in den französischen städten zu
vermeiden wenn sie eine prognose von mir
haben wollen ob das gelingt das nicht
gelingen wir werden solche phänomene
hier bekommen und wir müssen diese
probleme sozusagen schärfer in den blick
nehmen wir müssen sich doch noch
deutlich kriegen das im moment zumindest
die situation in deutschland sicher noch
verschärft ist jetzt im vergleich zur
schweiz
aber was ich die fragen möchte herr
merken wenn ich ihnen zuhöre kriege ich
den eindruck sie sind wirklich auch
persönlich besorgt sie glauben hier
kommen ganz große probleme auf uns zu
verstehe ich das richtig auch da ist
schon was dran ich glaube dass das weit
übertrieben wird das natürlich auch eine
frage von mehr als verhältnis es gibt ja
folgenlosen dass 2050 in unseren ländern
der muslimischen mehrheit sein wird das
halte ich für ganz abwegig
aber wir werden in bestimmten hatten
sich derweil nichts dafür spricht es
gibt ja von euro staat schon solche
sozusagen vorausschauenden berechnungen
kalkulationen die sagen allerdings die
letzte die ich kenne ist von 2011 die
sagen in größeren städten in deutschland
österreich holland schweiz schweiz
vielleicht nicht wird nicht genannt
dabei werden wir einzelne muslimische
mehrheit
aber das spricht nichts dafür dass wir
in unseren ländern muslimische
mehrheiten haben
immerhin darf ich darauf hinweisen dass
in dieser euro-staat studie gesagt wird
prognosen zum ende dieses jahrhunderts
hin sind nicht mehr zu geben
aber warum wäre das zum beispiel ein
problem also warum nicht wenn ich die
frage nach ihrer besorgen ist nennen sie
die statistik dass möglicherweise nicht
wir haben keinen und es hat über keinen
sinn dass in unseren diskussionen zu
verschweigen ich verteidige eine
liberale grundposition wie sie es hat
keinen sinn zu ignorieren dass wir
keinen einzigen islamischen staat haben
der demokratisch wäre immer wird
indonesien und seine hoch defekte
demokratie sind auch andere muslime als
jahr erwischen wir haben zehn länder auf
dieser welt in der auf homosexualität
die todesstrafe steht ausschließlich
muslimischen land islamischen länder
alle diese dinge sollten wir nicht
ignorieren wir sollten also sehen dass
in den ländern wo der islam nicht nur
die dominante religion ist und das
öffentliche leben die politik und die
rechtsordnung bestimmt norden strukturen
so sei in kraft sind die wir hier nicht
wollen und gegen die wir uns verteidigen
sollten das ist meine einzige besorgnis
ich glaube nicht dass wir vor
irgendeiner katastrophe des abendlands
stehen aber wir sollten die augen offen
halten
das denke ich auch und ich denke aber
auch dass dauern vielleicht ein blick in
die geschichte gar nicht so schlecht ist
denn viele dieser debatten die jetzt
geführt grenzen ja auch in unseren
eigenen traditionen auch drin standen
stattgefunden also sowohl in bezug auf
das verhältnis von mann und frau
ich erinnere nur kurz daran 1971 erst
das wahlrecht der frauen in der schweiz
dann
fundamentalistische kräfte und
freiheitlich denkenden kräfte gehen noch
weiter zurück in der aufklärung wo man
wirklich versucht hat erstmal die
meinungsfreiheit die freie
meinungsäußerung durchzusetzen also
verschiedene dieser dieser werte die
jetzt verhandelt werden sind
errungenschaften die auch gegen
fundamentale kräfte und gegen gegen
aufklärerische position oder und
freiheitliche überzeugung durchgesetzt
herren werden die religion und von daher
ist doch in die trotzdem die grundfrage
wie und die aufklärer worden meinen
augen ja äußerst optimistisch städten
wirklich ein äußerst optimistisch das
menschenbild und die haben daran
geglaubt wir können die menschen davon
überzeugen dass freiheit attraktiv ist
wenn man die menschen nur lässt dann
haben sie freude an der freiheit dann
kommen sie dazu zu diskutieren und und
eben irgendwie gewisse aufgaben verloren
ich glaube wir haben wir sind
verunsichert ja ich glaube dieser
optimismus der in diesen texten drin ist
ist heute lese ich in wenigen texten
oder in der home ist das grundvertrauen
dass der mensch lernfähig ist dass wir
durch gespräch einander näher kommen
können
das kleinste projekte eben von
theaterprojekten spielenachmittage dass
das etwas bringt um geselligkeit das war
ein ganz großer wert sich auszutauschen
sich zu treffen bei essen zu streiten
zusammen also alle das vertrauen in
diese praktiken sozialen praktiken
ich glaube das ist in einem kleinen ort
und wenn ich noch mal dass eine
ernsthaft gestellte frage auch an mich
selber wie können wir gegen
fundamentalistische strömungen eben die
dinge stark machen die mir persönlich
liegt sehen die uns vielleicht lieb sind
also die wir nicht aufgeben möchten
und dann denke ich schon dass sind alles
so unspektakuläre dinge oder es ist
nicht mit einem kampfflugzeug irgendwo
hinfliegen und und irgendwie und es ist
auch nicht indonesien jetzt zu
reformieren sondern es gibt schon fragen
was machen wir jetzt hier in den
gesellschaften in denen wir leben und
wenn ich das ist auch ein bisschen in
ein anderes land geschaut aber zum
beispiel und dass auch sie in frankreich
es wurden alle kleines projekt in den
banlieues abgeschafft der autoproduktion
vorher alles das was im kleinen tropfen
gewesen im ganzen bildschirm
sozialbudget dieses landes
kleinste summen die da eingespart wurde
man hat alles gestrichen das war ist
jetzt irgendwie mehr als zehn jahre her
und das fehlt das sind kontakte das sind
alles getragen das heißt sie sind
eigentlich optimistisch sie sagen lasst
uns glauben und die werte der aufklärung
dann kommt es gut
und dann schrieb ich ketzerisch hinten
nach ihre werte der ausstellung haben
beispielsweise guantanamo nicht
verhindert absolut man wäre enorm der
aufklärung spricht muss natürlich das
unbehagen dieser auf oder eben diese
selbstkritik die nötig ist immer auch
mitdenken also und das wäre natürlich
völlig verkürzt eben und sie sind auch
innerhalb der aufklärung kulturen die
gebildet herausgegangen sind also da
sind wir eben immer wieder in
zertifizieren komplexen pluralen system
über die wir jetzt sprechen aber ich
denke trotzdem in einem punkt bin ich
einfach optimistisch bzw
nicht mal optimistisch und ich glaube
das ist unsere einzige chance dieses
gespräch wirklich zu führen nicht
abstrakt zu sagen wir müssen das
gespräch mit den muslimen für sondern es
ganz konkret tun und dann nämlich muss
ich auch sagen mach ich vielleicht noch
zu wenig einfach wirklich hingehen diese
ganzen foren ich kenne auch in die
christliche gemeinden die dann die
muslimische gemeinde einlädt und
jüdische mit einbezieht das sind
offenbar so unspektakuläre kleine
aktionen im gemeinden oder dass man dann
eben die asylanten im chor mitsingen
lässt und plötzlich sind sie kennen es
gibt viele kleine und das tönte
unspektakulärer sind nicht die ganz
großen dinge die man da jetzt im
fernsehen sagen kann
aber das ist so richtig damit eben eine
gesellschaft zusammenwächst und diese
gespräche funktionieren also ich bin
ganz dankbar dass ich ein bisschen
meinen skeptischen ton jetzt abfangen
moderieren kann ich bin eher schon
optimistisch was die durchsetzung der
werte der aufklärung betrifft
langfristig wir sollten nur die
schwierigkeit und die größe der probleme
nicht ignorieren
sie haben recht diese werte mussten hier
durchgesetzt werden gegen ein
fundamentalistisches christentum aber
das christentum hat das purgatorium der
aufklärung hinter sich und große teile
des islam haben das nicht nicht der
islam schlechthin aber erhebliche teile
des islam hängen einer vormodernen
religion an
auch das zu ignorieren sollte mir nicht
ich glaube aber dass wir langfristig
eine sozusagen einen durchsetzen dieser
liberalen werte der aufklärung erleben
werden und sehr viele muslime die jetzt
in unsere länder kommen werden das nach
und nach annehmen wir sehen nur im
moment eine gegenläufige tendenz die
junge generation radikalisiert sich
stärker als die eltern die hier
hergekommen sind und wir müssen
versuchen dagegen was zu machen
der punkt ist nur ist darauf will ich
eigentlich investieren es ist nicht nur
eine aufgabe für uns die wir nur
hinreichend geschickt anpacken müssen
dann kann sie gelöst werden ist eine
aufgabe für die migranten und und in dem
punkt widerspreche ich den beiden
münklers nachdrücklich das hauptproblem
auf der seite der migranten ist die
religion
wir müssen sehen dass wir dieses problem
lösen können den leuten auch deutlich
machen auch in streit um die burka wir
verbieten die burka nicht wir werden
aber dafür sorgen dass eure kinder hier
die normale liberale erziehung in
unseren schulen kriegen und wir wollen
sie zur autonomen personen erziehen die
am ende die frau in die am ende selber
entscheiden werden wir werden nicht
euren maximen folgen und sagen ihr könnt
an der sonder erziehung für eure kinder
reklamieren
das geht doch da kommt dann doch auch
die grund philosophische frage aber auch
auf mit welchem recht verteidigen die
eigentlich unsere kultur also kann jeder
einfach hingehen und sagen
entschuldigung hier gilt jetzt dass ihr
habt euch anzupassen also in stichwort
wenn ich das noch sagen darf dazu nennen
das ein sehr schwieriger begriff kultur
und die integrationsdebatte wird unter
philosophie unter drei verschiedenen
begriffen von integration geführt
soziale integration dann eine art
zivilgesellschaftlicher normativ
orientierter und dann kulturelle
integration im engel
sind also von leibnitz bis was weiß ich
dass ledger kann man nicht nur nicht
verlangen es hat keinen sinn dass
irgendwie nahe bringen sollen außer in
der üblichen art der erziehung
aber wir haben natürlich schon ein
intuitives empfinden von dem was unsere
umgebung ausmacht und ein gefühl der
inneren heimat
ich fühle mich nicht nur äußerlich hier
in meinem heimatland sozusagen zuhause
ich fühle mich auch innerlich zu hause
und das hat vielerlei kulturelle wurzeln
und den leuten sozusagen die furcht
davor nicht zu nehmen dass das verloren
gehen könnte wäre ein schwerer fehler
und davor fürchten sich viele leute die
mögen das so deutlich nicht artikulieren
können aber ich glaube der verlust der
drohende verlust der inneren heimat ist
das was diese menschen fürchten ich
fühle mich nicht mehr zu hause aber die
menschen die hierher kommen die haben
doch auch eine innere heimat die sie
dann plötzlich aufgeben müssen also noch
einmal eine frage wer darf eigentlich
wissen in der heimat sozusagen
verteidigen oder ungleich leute müssen
sich aneinander
wir haben hier dinge hinzunehmen diese
menschen kommen mit ihrer eigenen
inneren heimat ist nicht zulässig ihnen
zu sagen es ist ja alles fallen lassen
einschließlich der religion das absolut
unzulässig also wir haben auch sozusagen
integrationsleistungen mit diesen
fremden kulturen zu vollbringen wir
haben nur eine grundlegende norm in
ordnung die wir nicht preisgeben und da
müssen wir sozusagen unnachgiebig sein
dann möchte ich zum schluss gerne wissen
kann denn die burka zu inneren heimat
dazu gehören gehabt
ich kann das nicht gegeben einen anderen
[Musik]
letztgültig beantworten und ich find die
frage schwierig für mich ist sie keine
heimat für mich ist die fremd und ich
hoffe dass meine nichten keine tragen
und keine schon gar nicht tragen müssen
so weit würde ich gehen ob ich würde
kein verbot und heißt
also ich glaube dass für die frauen die
burka tragen dass sehr wohl einen teil
ihrer inneren heimat in diesem sinn sein
kann
sie signalisieren aber sehr vielen
anderen leuten die das ihre innere
heimat keine brücke zulässt zu der
inneren heime der mehrheitsbevölkerung
hier und hier müssen wir versuchen
vermittlungen zu schaffen
ein generelles burka verbot würde ich
ablehnen
genauso wie sie vielen dank danke für
dieses gespräch vor ort der merkel
dankeschön nächste woche begrüßt sie an
meiner stelle wieder einmal ein
gastmoderator dieses jahr ist das
wolfram eilenberger er ist chefredaktor
des magazins in berlin und die man
vielleicht auch bekannt als
diskussionsteilnehmer in unseren
sternstunden am kommenden sonntag
diskutiert er über das böse im menschen
mit dem historiker jörg sabrowski und
dem gefängnisarzt und tatort
schauspieler joe bausch eine woche
später ist wieder zeit für den
philosophischen stammtisch mein thema
ist die beihilfe zum suizid wenn sie
eine meinung haben zur frage wie
selbstbestimmt ein suizid sein kann und
ob die schweiz als destination für
sterbe touristen dienen soll
dann schreiben sie mir an philosophie
des fch jetzt gleich geht es weiter mit
der sternstunde kunst mit einem porträt
der künstlerin valie export sie hat sich
in aktionen wie dem busen top und ost
kino ebenfalls mit dem weiblichen körper
und der selbstbestimmung befasst heute
ist die 76 und eine ikone
ich bedanke mich für das interesse und
wünsche ihnen einen guten sonntag
[Musik]